[Music]
[Applause]
that's a great question uh let me think
about this
i was very interested in artificial
intelligence and its potential and its
power to change the world my research
interests include radicalization on the
internet so
i automatically came in touch with
natural language processing discovered
this interest in me and and the
potential that that ai would have on you
know in society that's why i decided to
go deeper
[Music]
with the cs2 to 4u project we
looked at state-of-the-art research and
applied it
to
real-world customer chat information
across different companies different
industries and then observe the effects
of ai understanding emotion to be able
to predict the business success for me
as a scientist it's always nice to have
the freedom to link your courses and the
skills you acquire to your actual
interests and your actual research
projects the quality of the program to
support the people that you get to know
because this is an international
community joining the program you learn
a lot conceptually in terms of hands-on
experience
[Music]
you are not left alone like in many
other online courses the people from
stanford did a good job building
learning groups and putting us together
with people from similar time zones
[Music]
my greatest learning success was how
much i learned about project management
time management you will feel super
empowered and make a lot of new
acquaintances gave me confidence to
tackle those ai problems to find the
courage basically spearhead new projects
and find new ideas i now have acquired
the confidence
to start my next startup in the ai space
and drive it
this course was a transformational phase
in my life